では よろしくお願いします
で  すぐ今日の話が始まります
で 渇愛と不死という 仏教では大変有名な言葉二つなんですね
で まあ一応副題は生存欲を乗り越える涅槃への道ということで
あの不死っていうのはパーリ語でアマタ
アマタとアマタ 我々はアマタと発音しますけど
アマタなんですね これの同義語がございましてね
ニッバーナ 涅槃の同義語としてよく使われ使われています
だから不死とは涅槃のことなんです
いわゆる解脱悟りのことなんです
仏道を全体的に示すためにも使うんですね
仏道 仏教そのものに対しても
不死という言葉を使うんですね
アマタマッゴー アマタンダンマンとかね
もうダンマ法ですね 真理は不死の真理を取られているとかね
仏道というのは修行 それも不死の道とも言いますね
それからまた同義語ありまして
ケーマ 安穏でしょうかね
日本訳は それでアマタですね
まあ使っている言葉で
アバヤ 何の恐怖も何の不安もない境地
それからパッサディ 何の重さもない
すごくなんか軽い状態
何の重みもない状態 これ心の状態なんですね
あるいは寂静という言葉でもよろしいと思います
パッサディは それからニローダ
寂滅という言葉もありますね
それもアマタの同義語です
涅槃の同義語なんですね
寂滅っていうのは 我々の生きることはなんかものすごいゴウゴウと燃えている
火事に例えられてますよ
あの お釈迦様の最初の五人の弟子の方々はね
コンランニャ ワッパ バッディ
マハナ マッサジという五人の比丘たちがまず預流果に悟りましたね
しかし 阿羅漢にならなかったんですね
それでお釈迦様は五人をあるどこかに連れて行って
静かなところに連れて行って
燃えるというタイトルの経典を
別にお釈迦様はタイトルつけてないんです
後でタイトルつけてまったけどね
ある教えを教えたんですね
すべては燃えてますよと
サッバン ビッケー アーディッタン
すべて燃えているんだよと
だから次にキンチャ ビッケー
アーディッタン それでチャック
目ですね 燃えてますよと
何で燃えているのかと
貪瞋痴で燃えています
で それでゲンニービーセシンですね
燃えていますよと 貪瞋痴で
また色受想行 色って五蘊
体構成している五つ それも貪瞋痴でゴウゴウと燃えていますよということを言ったところで
その五人の方々は執着を捨てることをできたんですね
自分の体に対する それで大阿羅漢になったんです
そういうことで この恐ろしく燃えている存在に対して
寂静 寂滅なんです 火が消えた状態ということで
涅槃にもその言葉を使います
という言葉の定義は それからこの
まあ一応経典から取り出しましたから
このアングッテルニカーのね
で 経典グループがありましてね
このグループの中のアイデアは省略しました
まずケーマとは何やといって
第1 善行  第2 善行  第3 善行
第4 善行に達して それから無色界の
で 赤さないで空無辺 色無辺とかね
なんとかね アーキンチャンに会ったの
空無辺と えっと 非想非想非想非想定というんですね
まあよくわからない まあわからなくても結構です
というのを説明する時間がないんです
この八つの禅定に達して
それから一切煩悩をなくして
滅尽定という阿羅漢に達するサマーディですね
そのサマーディに達することが安穏であると
それから安穏に達したという次の経典
それで比丘が修行して
この第1から 8番目の禅定と 9番目になる阿羅漢の禅定に入ったら
それで達したことになりますよというふうに説明に行くんですね
ということは アマタとは涅槃ですね
あるいは仏道を修行して
心を集中力を上げてサマーディを作ったりして
煩悩を減らしたりして
やがて煩悩をなくしたりする道が不死の道なんですね
はい それからもう一つ
同じ経典グループの中でバッバという言葉が出てくるんですね
バッバというのは資格という言葉なんですね
ラーガン欲 ドーサン怒り
モーハン無知 コーダン瞋恚
ウパナーハン恨み マッカン疑然
パラーサン欺瞞 イッサン嫉妬
マッチャリア惜しむこと
物惜しみですね 以上の 9つがない人は
阿羅漢に達するための資格者であると説かれるんです
で 経典二つここで縮んであります
一番目の経典は 仏道でね
アマタに不死に達する資格がない人っていうのは
欲があって 怒りがあって
無知があって 瞋恚があって
恨みがあったりとかね
そういう人は失格者であると
じゃあその 9つがない人が資格者なんですね
阿羅漢に達する資格 があるんですね
それから修行しなくちゃあかんです
バッバは英語で言えばクオリファイドという意味もありますので
仏教用語でクオリファイドパーソンとは阿羅漢のことなんです
バッボウプリソンと言えば阿羅漢聖者なんですね
はい それから不死というのはただの単語ではありません
これは専用語で言えば検証するもので
で 体験するもの 経験するものなんですね
自分が達するものなんです
だから ある我々は達するある境地のことなんですね
この不死という名前でいて
いわゆる涅槃 解脱っていうことですね
アマタンテーサンビッカレサッチカタン
イエサンカーヤガターサティサッチカタ
で カーヤガターサティっていうのは皆様ご存知だと思いますね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのは
サティパッターナスッタンテから教えられているんですね
四念処 四念処経というね
で 一応今パティパダーでも連載しています
四念処経はね 結構長い経典ですけど
この四念処経で体の体にサティ気づき入れなさい
感覚に気づき入れなさい
心の働きに気づき入れなさい
それから現象 物事を通して見て
そちらにも気づき入れなさいという 4つ
身受心法というんですね
その 4つ こちらの一つだけ取り上げたんですけど
一応他の経典で他の 4つも入っています
で 身随念処ですかね 体の動きに対する気づきを体験する人は
不死を体験したことになりますと
いわゆる皆様も今実践している気づきの瞑想を成長していろいろ体験が起こるんですよ
そのその体験によって
何かしら不死の境地を体験していくんです
よく頭で理解できないんだから
この究極的な最終ステージに行くまではそんな実感はないんですけど
一応不死を体験させようとしているんですね
また お釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
ヨーチェワッササタンジーウェアパッサンアマタンパダン
エーカーハンジービタンセイヨウパッサトアマタンパダン
これダンマパダで不死を検証せず
百年生きるよりは不死を検証して 1日生きることがまさるんですと
で 不死を検証することができれば
あなた悟りに達したら今日死にますよと言われても
それ構いませんよと 修行しなかったら百年生きられますよと言って言われても
百年を捨てて いえ 今日死んでも構いませんから
悟りに達しますと言わなくちゃあかんですね
それぐらい価値があるんです
で 生きるということは輪廻転生することだからね
これを限りない苦しみの
だから限りない苦しみを選ぶか
今日 1日で苦しみを終わるのかっていうことですからね
だから人は長生きしたっても
お釈迦様言うのは何の意味もないんだよと
ただ欲で怒りで 嫉妬で
憎しみで苦しんで悩んで
何やってるのかと もし煩悩をなくして心安らかにしたならば
その人の命が一日であっても
それは素晴らしい命である
生き方である この場合も不死という言葉を使っているんですね
涅槃に アマタンパダ もう一度戻ります
えーと これでパダンという言葉がありますね
パダンというのはもうすごいパーリ語でいろんな意味がありまして
足跡にもパダンと言うんですよ
一歩一歩という意味でもパダンと言うんですね
で それからパダンというのはステップ
境地という意味でも使いますね
言葉にも使います WORD
言葉 単語 だから不死っていうのは我々が達する一つの境地なんです
いわゆる最終的に達する究極の境地に不死という言葉を使っているんです
はい 次 不死に達する道
身受心法の随念は不死に達する道ですね
それを前に説明しました
四念処経であるヴィパッサナー瞑想を実践することしかもうないんです
タッサカーエーカーヤヌパッシーナヴィーラトヨーカーヤスミンチャンドソウパヒーヤティ
チャンダッサパハナアマタンスッチカタンホーティ
例えば 体のことを観察していくと
体は微細に瞬間瞬間いろんなことを変わっていく
新たなものが生まれてくる
このプロセス見えてくるんですね
そうすると なんだこれはと
体体と思っていたんだけど
これはそうじゃないんだと
瞬間瞬間変化して消えていく
ある流れだけですよと
こちら固体した私の体というべきものは何もないやと思ったところで
チャンダという 欲望がなくなるんですね
欲望がなくなります 欲望がなくなると不死を体験します
こちらで欲と言っているのは渇愛のことなんですね
私たちは肉体にすごい愛着を持っているんですね
肉体があると思っているんですね
これはしっかりと観察してみると
肉体と肉体があると言えなくなっちゃうんです
これが肉体と示すものはなくなっちゃうんです
それぐらい複雑なことが絡んでずっと変わっていくんですね
それを発見すれば 渇愛か欲がなくなるんですね
はい もう一度定義に行きます
エヴァンブッテソービクブガワンタンエタドオーチャ
アマタンアマタンティバンテーブッチャティ
カタマンヌコウバンテーアマタン
カトモアマタガミニマッゴーティ
ヨーコビク ラーガッカヨドーサッカヨモーハッカヨ
イダンブッチャティアマタン
アヤメーヴァアリオアッタンギコマッゴーアマタガミーマッゴー
セイエティダンサッマディティサッマサンカッポサッマワーチャーヨサッマカンマンサッマサマーディまで八正道ですね
日本訳を見てください
ションシ 不死 不死といいます
何が不死なのですか？不死に達する道は何ですか？とお釈迦様に聞くんですね
で お釈迦様は答える 貪瞋痴の滅尽
不死です 不死とは貪瞋痴を残りなくなくすことである
正八正道は正見正思惟という八正道がありますね
正八正道は不死に達する道です
そうすると 前 四念処経のヴィパッサナー実践すれば悟れますよと言ったでしょうに
こちらは八正道なんですね
これ全然違いはありません
同じものなんです で お釈迦様が四念処を実践する者は八正道を実践している
八正道を実践したいと思う者が四念処を実践するべきであると説かれてありますから
同じものなんです はい
これが定義なんですね
不死とは涅槃のことで
いわゆる貪瞋痴がない状態に不死と呼ぶんです
放逸とは死という意味です
アッパマードーアマタパダン
パマードーマッチュノーパダン
アッパマッターナミーヤンティ
イエーパマッタヤタハマタ
これでじゃあ意味も出してから説明しましょう
不放逸は不死の道   この場合は言葉という意味で取っても構いません
が パダンということだからややこしいんですよ
不放逸イコール不死です
放逸は死の道 死という意味です
不放逸を実践する人は死なない
いわゆる不死になる 私は死なないと訳しましたけど
不死になる まあ死なないですね
ナミーヤって 放逸の人はすでに死んでいるようなものに等しい
はい では放逸不放逸なんですかね
不放逸っていうのは 気づきを実践する人にしか使わないんです
ヴィパッサナー実践なさっている方々は
この実況中継しているんですね
実況中継がサティではないんです
あれはただ言葉を回転するだけで
しかし この言葉を回転すると
そのその現象に気づくんです
手を上げます 上げます
上げます と言っている場合は
手が上がっている感覚に気づいているんですね
物体身体という物体が移動することに気づいているんですね
この気づくことが不放逸
他の人々はいつだって放逸なんですね
妄想している時 ものすごい放逸的な生き方なんですね
いわゆる今の瞬間でいないんですね
晩御飯のことを今思い出したら
もう放逸です 今の瞬間じゃないんだからね
だから今の瞬間から飛び出した人々に
過去に将来に行ったら
お釈迦様 あの人死んでるんだよと
だから我々は今に気づくということは
一般人というのはほとんどしていないんですね
ですから お釈迦様から見れば
みんなまあ死人だらけ
だから死人は何も知らないんだからね
ただ腐るだけ臭いだけ
だから人間はそんなもんなんですね
そういうことで 不放逸
サティの実践 気づきの実践を行っている場合は不放逸
その瞬間で生きているんです
手を上げる上げる上げる下げる下げる下げる
左足を上げる 運ぶ 下ろす
という あの瞬間で確実に生きているんです
それでサティが自分目に覚めたら
サティの実践が成功したら
もう不死なんですね いわゆる悟りに達しているんです
これ 時間的に言えば 常に今の瞬間にいられることが不死であって
時間ずれる場合はね まあ死人なんです
これはダンパでの有名な言葉で
はい これで経典の紹介を終わります
それからアマタとマタ
不死と死 仏教的な見方を解説します
それからだらだらと私の説明になります
また繰り返しますが 用語の意味
アマタ不死とは涅槃解脱に使う同義語です
一般の人は究極的なに良いとされる不死
至福 安穏 寂静 無為 涅槃などの単語を解脱を示すために使われています
お釈迦様がこういう工夫をなさったんです
人間が究極的な良いと思ったものに使った単語は何なのかと
別に誰も究極的な良いところに達したわけじゃなくて
妄想するんですよ 思考するんですよ
大体生きるということはね
まあ苦しいものであると
大変であると 生きることに意味があるのかどうか
そういうことを考える人々
で そういうことを考える人々は
まあ人間にとって究極の幸せは何なのかと
まあヨーロッパでもユートピアという考えがあったんですね
ユースロムさんたちでもね
ユートピアというね ありえない話をね
で 共産主義者のユートピアっていうのは
この世の中で作るものなんですね
仏教から見ると これ絶対ありえないんです
ただ いろんなくだらんことを妄想するんですよ
労働者の国 労働者が全て支配して
で 嘘ばっかしで 労働者が支配する世界っていうのは現れないんです
いつでも権力者支配するんです
で そこでも何でも揃っている世界
搾取は一切ない世界 中国も共産主義ですけど
搾取はないんですかね
搾取そのものでしょう
一般の労働者たちはね
ろくに食べるものもなく
寝るどころもなくて 小さな
まあ日本人だったら一人やっと住めるところで
人ぐらい寝て仕事をして品物を売ってますよ
世の中に で まあそれって搾取でしょ
まあとにかくまあそんな政治の話はどうでもいいんですけど
で とにかく西洋の方でユートピアという概念が現れてきてね
そうやって人間使う単語だけ
お釈迦様は涅槃に使うんです
ですから 涅槃にたくさん同義語があります
例えばお釈迦様は まあこの現代というかね
この 20世紀あたりで生まれたならば
あるいは 19 世紀後半でも生まれたならば
ユートピアということも妥当でしょうね
しかし キリスト教の楽園という言葉を使わないと思います
楽園 天国という言葉はインドにもありましたからね
それには笑っちゃいますね
ただ イメージ的にね 究極な幸福に達したいというね
いう場合は概念ですね
その単語使うんですよ
例えば涅槃というニッバーナという言葉も
インドの宗教にもあります
まあヒンドゥ教で使ってなかったんですけど
仏教を壊すために仏教が広がったところで
仏教を全部使うことにしたんですね
サマーディとかね ニルバーナとかね
で まあ一応そういう単語があったんです
単語があるんだけど 誰もそれって経験したのかって
誰も経験してないんですよ
それからブッダという言葉も
あったんです それはもうただブッディ
ノレッジ ウィスダム 知恵という言葉から作った名詞なんですね
まあブッディといえば
ある状況でブッダといえば人なんですね
プレセントですね 英語でもあれ ER
かMN入れちゃうと人になっちゃいますね WORK
といえば仕事で WORKMAN
といえば仕事をする人ということになっちゃうんですね
あるいはWORKER ER
も入れられますね WORKMAN
かWORKER だからMN入れるかER入れるかで
まあそれはまあ他の言語でもありますし
ブッディというノレッジ
これノレッジある人がブッダなんですね
それでサンマサンブッダというのは完全なもう何も欠けていることはない
パーフェクト パーフェクトの智者
そこでインドではこの人間というのはバカだな
無知だな 何もわからないんだなだなという考えあったんですね
それをお釈迦様は使ったんですね
無明という言葉で そこで無明がなくなってなくなるということは
完全な智慧が現れるということ
アイディアがあったんだけど
誰もやったことはない
あの青い鳥みたいな話なんですね
あのヒノドリみたいな感じで
もうアイディアがあるんだけど
誰も会ったことはない
経験したことはない それでお釈迦様は初めて世の中にブッダになりましたと
修行を終了しましたと
知るべきことは知り終えたと
煩悩をなくしたと 不死なる境地に達しましたと堂々と発表する
疑った人もいたんですよ
で まあ結構いたと思いますよ
だから仏教を広げたんですよ
疑う人々は今と違って隠れて悪口を言うんじゃなくて
言って会う 会って話すんです
すごい質が悪いんですね
日本だったら隠れてインターネットであだ名で暴言吐いたい放題吐いちゃいますからね
あれすごい文化的にやり方ですね
そういう態度ではなくて
堂々と言って あなたブッダと言ってるんですけど
なんでそう言うのかと
いうふうに質問をするんです
それで説明したら その人は仏教徒になる
ある王様があのね インドではね
サンジェーベルラティプッテやらマッカリゴーサリやらね
パクダカッチャヤやら
アジタケーサカムバラやらね
ニガンタナータプッタやら
もう 6人のとし終えた
また長い歴史のある たくさん弟子たちがいる先生たちがいますよと
しかし誰も私はブッダだよとか
修行終わった完成と言ってないんだと
そんなにそんなに派手に言ってないんだと
あんた若いでしょうと
なんでこう言うのかと
それでお釈迦様は説明したんですね
こういうこと こういうこと
こういうことだと それでその人はまた仏教になると
そういうことで で 何が言いたいかというと
この単語っていうのはインドにあったもので
お釈迦様がこの言葉だけではダメやと
それに足すないのかと調べて足したんです
しかし 一般的に考える不死
考える死対不死という意味ではありません
それでみんな間違ったところはそちらになるんですよ
これは皆様にも理解できると思います
不死と言った途端 あ 私は死なないというふうに思っちゃうでしょ
それが おかしいと みんな考えているのはどこかで生まれたいんですね
本当はこの世で死なない状況が欲しいんですよ
それは明確に あの キリスト教ではあるんですね
キリスト教ではイエス様がまた来るんです
来て 異教徒はみんな片っ端から殺して地獄に落として
神様を信じる人々だけの世界を作るんです
その完全な世界 あのクリスマス
もう皆様もうそろそろキリスト教になる時期ですから
あの あの クリスマス日
その前の日とか この新宿とか大きい街でちょっと夜散歩してください
スピーカーつけて棒にそこを
時々来る前にね 神様がそろそろ来ますよと
来て この世の中の不幸
不幸 不尽不尽は全てなくしますよと
悪いことをする人々は
神を信じないとみんな地獄に落としますよと
みんな殺しちゃって地獄に落としますよと
それで早くもあなた方は神を信じなさいよというふうな素晴らしいメッセージを
言って歩くんです あれは福研なんとかというね
大変幸福な言葉なんですね
もう聞くたびに私は蹴っ飛ばしたくなっちゃうんですけどね
お前ら他の仕事ないのかと
その脅しに人を騙せると思いますかと
まあ日本人騙せますけど
日本人ってそれより忙しいんだからね
もうケーキ買わなくちゃとかね
もう飲み屋さんに行かなくちゃとかね
だから聞いてないだけ
それで このキリスト教の場合は
将来いつでも神様どうか分からないんだけど
延期するんですね 来る日は
ものすごい延期延期ばっかりで
いつ来るかわからない
で 神様が来て完全な世界を作って
他の人類みんな処分しちゃって
永遠の地獄に落として完全な世界を作るんですね
その世界で誰も死なない
年取らない だから何か分からないんですね
この地球上で不死の世界を作るんですね
で支配するのは王様はイエス様です
ユダヤ教のユダヤ人の民族
12種類ありますから
そちらそちらも王に認定する
王の上いるのはエンペラーですからね
で よくあんなこと考えるんだなと思いますけどね
結局我々もキリスト教に笑ってる場合じゃないんですね
我々も不死と思った途端
思うのは 私がこのままで死なないでいるだろうという気持ちなんです
それでキリスト教の一部あるかもしれませんだけど
普通 神を信仰する宗教で不死不死という言葉を使いますけど
人間が死ぬんですよ 洗礼を受けても
毎日曜日教会に行っても
やっぱり我々より病気になっちゃうし
不幸は多いし どうかわからないんですね
もう唯一正しい宗教であるイスラム教にしたったらね
イスラム教の国々のあるあの不幸
あの苦しみ あの苦難 サウジアラビアにしたっても切りがないんです
毎金曜日教会に行ってから
あの 公で人を殺すんですよ
処刑するんです 外で ちょっとしたことで
だからみんなそれ見学に行くんです
あれってどんな気持ちなのかと
で 私たちは 我々の目の前でこうやって残酷に殺害することではなくて
事故を起こすことでも見たくないでしょう
なんかえっとしますでしょうに
人を不幸になるのは見たくないんですよ
皆様もやっぱりどこかでちょこっとでも事故を起こすとちょっと気になっちゃうんですね
私もそうなんですね 私は運転できないからね
誰かが運転していただきますけど
その時でも もし道路で事故あったら
運転する方は私はまっすぐ見てくださいと
見ないでくださいと なぜかというと
見たらなんかすごく 嫌だな
こんなことあってという悲しい気分になるんです
そうすると自分が精神不安定になっちゃって
また自分を事故起こしちゃいますからね
で で 普通人間っていうのは
あまり宗教ない人間でも
そういうすごく心優しいんですよ
そこで言いたいのは  唯一正しい宗教であるイスラム教であったっても
イスラム教の国々には何の安らぎも幸せもない
金はあるかもしれませんだけど
で だからその方々はこう考えるんですよ
この世でみんな死にますよと
死んでから天国に生まれます
そこで死なないと ってやり方があるんですね
それは違います なぜ違いますかというと
これはあまりにも低次元的な無知な思考なんです
なぜかというと 生まれたら
現れたら 現れたものが必ず消えるんです
私たちは今生きていると言ってるでしょ
生きているということは消えることなんです
お腹が空く 生きているでしょ？ご飯を食べる
満腹になるでしょ？美味しく感じるでしょ？前と違うでしょ？今の自分は変わったでしょ
それでだるくなっちゃって
寝るでしょ 体が変わるんです
で また寝て目が覚めたらまたお腹が空いていて
また楽しくご飯食べる
で いろんなことをやって変化しているんですね
この変化に生きているというんですよ
これ 死なないと言ったら変化しないって意味でしょ
どうですかね そんなことってあり得る？まあ冗談で天国言いたいんだけど
天国に 神を信じる人々は天国に生まれたらいきなり置物で
置物で 置物で生まれるんだよと
ステンレススチールみたいに
アルミみたいに アルミってちょっと腐敗しますね
まあじゃあ金にしましょうか
金とかダイヤみたいな感じで
そのまま変化しない これって生きていることですかね
もし歩いたり喋ったりすると変化でしょ
神は永遠なりと言ったっても
あの人はいろんなことをやっているでしょう
いろんなことをやるためにやるっていうことは変化でしょう
だから なんかこの物事をあまりにも知らないが上に
あまりにも感情で愛着があった故に
あんな変なことを考えちゃったんです
自分が死にたくないんですよ
それがなんで認めないんですかね
なんで自分が死にたくないんですかね
愛着あるんだからなんです
肉体に それに妄想して知らない境地を考えちゃう
それより先に自分が死にたくない
それは何だろうやと 私は生きてきた
生きてて 生きてるってことはなんでなんだろうやと
ちょっと考えた方がいいんじゃない？そうすると無常のおかげで生きてるんだと
つまらなくなったら 気分が落ち込んだら音楽を聴く
そこであの振動が耳に触れると
脳の中で聴覚を作って気持ちよくしてくれる
変化でしょ 特に日本の皆様方はよく泣き
泣いたいでしょ だから歌を聴いて泣く
あれは怒りを刺激しているんです
別れの歌とか で で 歌を聴く前にニコニコと笑っていたのに
プロの歌をね 生ででも聞いたらやっぱり泣いちゃう
あれ 変化でしょ 前と今の自分が違うでしょうに
死なないためには 今の体が変化しないことにならなくちゃあかんですよ
ステンレススチールにでもならないと
そうすると百年 二百年ぐらいで持てるでしょうね
あの鉄は一応変化しますけど
金も変化しますけどね
それでも我々から考えればね
まあ結構長い時間ですからね
だから肉体そうなったらどうなるんですかね
やっぱりちょっとしたことで壊れるようになっているんですよ
それでそのおかげで生きているんです
ちょっと空気を吸わないで５分いただけで死んじゃうんです
ものすごく脆いんですね
脆いんだから 壊れないように頑張ることに生きているというんです
そこで この肉体で この体で不死
死なない状態っていうのは
もう現代的に言えば小学生ぐらいの知識があっても思わないことなんです
小学生は科学を学ぶかどうかよくわかりませんだけど
それでも私は喋った小学生っていうのは結構頭がいいんですよ
とにかく私をなんとかで負けてやるぞと頑張っちゃうんですね
私ももう負けるもんかと対立しますけど
でも対立しながら この頭をすごく使うこと
頭をよく使えることにはすごく驚くんですね
ああ よかったと この子供たちは結構頭使ってるんだぞとか
だから変わらないものっていうのは
私たちの俗世間的に見ちゃうと
もうステンレススチールみたいなもんなんですよ
他は全部変わるんです
あの昔の生き物が今化石になっているでしょ
化石はあんまり我々に見える変化はないんですね
しかし 化石とは石なんですね
あれ 動物じゃないんです
動物の物質 全部溶けてしまっちゃったんです
溶けて消えて その代わりに他の成分が入って石になったんです
だから同じ動物の形になるんですね
だから不死になりたければ化石になるしかないね
でも化石も壊れますけど
まあそれでもまあ1万年ぐらいは残りますから
いいんじゃないですかね
皆さん 不死になりたいと思うならば
今日からさっさと化石になる技術を開発して化石になってください
長く生きたければ 100年
200年  300年生きたければ
ミイラになってみてください
すぐ だからこの世の中考える不死というこの概念があんまりにもおかしい
お釈迦様がこれありえないんだと
本当の不死を見つけたんです
俗的には生 生きることは善
死は悪 不死は財前という考えなんですね
みんなそう思ってるでしょ
生きることは素晴らしい
死ぬことまで言葉 死ぬという言葉さえ使わないでくださいと
亡くなられましたと言ってくださいと
あるいは天界に行きましたとかね
えーと 何て言ったら極楽道に何だらかんだらとかね
往生しましたとかね 死という言葉がすごい悪い言葉だと思っているんですね
そういうことで 生きることはなんて素晴らしいでしょうか
死ぬことはなんて悪いでしょうか
それだったら不死ということがなんて究極の素晴らしいことではないかと
と思っちゃう しかし そちらの問題は
生きることは本当に素晴らしいのかと
調べましょうよと 結論に達する前に
死ぬことって何なのかと調べましょうよとお釈迦様は調べるんですね
それで生きることは苦であると発見したでしょ
生きることは苦だったら
不死っていうのは 永遠の苦でしょう
仏教は 生と死は苦ですと解きますね
生死を乗り越えることは涅槃イコール不死です
仏教は 仏教では生も死も苦です
この場合は 誕生日と死ぬことじゃないんです
誕生を示す 産むことを示す単語は別にパーリ語であります
その代わりに似ている生という言葉のジャーティという言葉を使うんです
死は何のオシャレもなく
死 その言葉を使うんです
仏教では生も苦で 死も苦なんです
死は面白いじゃないんです
生まれることも苦で 死ぬことも苦であるんだから
だったら生死を乗り越えなくちゃいけないんです
いわゆる不死だけではなくて
不生不死でなければいけません
そこは他の哲学者たちが間違ったところなんです
不死だけを謳っていたんだけど
不称謳わないんですね
だから仏教では気を遣ってないんだけど
不死と一緒に不称という言葉も使うんです
涅槃にアジャーティン
アマラン アカタン アサンカタン
ニッバーナ ヴィラジャン
ヴィータマラン たくさん言葉があります
アジャーティ 不称 アマタン
不死 それが涅槃です 生死
生きる命 これに行く前にもうちょっと説明した方がいいと思いますね
あの子供が生まれることにはウッパティとかなんとか言いますよ
で その単語ではなくて
ジャーティ生という単語を使っているんです
なぜかというと 生きるということは生死の連続なんです
何か死んで何か生まれる
この流れ 絶えない 連続して流れるんです
これに大雑把で生きているんだと言うんです
生きるということは 生死
生死 生死 生死の流れなんです
だって一度も生まれた人は死なないでしょ
死ぬ時は別人だからね
だから赤ちゃんが生まれた瞬間で
お腹に中にいた赤ちゃんと違うんです
だから生まれたっていうことは
お腹の中にある赤ちゃんが本当は死んだんです
死んで瞬時に隙間なく新たなものがあるんです
で 赤ちゃんが生まれたというんです
その赤ちゃんもずっと死んで
死んで死んで 新たな新たな新たなものになるんです
これ かなりスピードに起こるんですよ
だから見てもよくわからないんです
かなりスピーディーに起こるんです
我々にはものすごい大雑把で派手でないとわからないんです
例えば呼吸するでしょう
吸ったら一瞬でそれで終わり
それから吐くということになっちゃうんです
それも生死なんです 吸うことにもいつでも生死があるんです
生まれて消えて 生まれて消えて
生まれて消えて ちょっと吸ったら
ある部分がある状況が消えちゃったんです
次に新たな状況 次に吸うんです
次にさらに吸うんです
それぞれ前の前の状況が消えて消えて消えて
いっぱい吸った状態になって
それから逆にならなくちゃあかんですね
ものを見る時でも同じことで
ずっとデータが流れて脳に入ってからまとめて視覚にするんであって
だからわからないんだよ
瞬間瞬間の変化 脳の中でも電気のスピードと同じスピードで電気が流れているんですよ
あちらこちら あちらこちら
神経細胞に信号を送って送って
またデータを受け取って
また別なところでまた一回処理して
それで何か視覚という幻覚を作るんです
本当に目に何が入るかと脳が知らないんです
そういうことで集中力を作っちゃうと
この早く物事生まれては死ぬ
生まれては死ぬ 生まれては死ぬ
何があろうと生まれては死ぬ
生まれては死ぬと 死んだらまた生まれるんだと
決して死んだものと生まれたものは
全く同じじゃないんです
ちょっと違うんです だから生まれた私は今ここにないんです
体変化するんだけど 生まれて死ぬんだけど
死んで生まれるんだけど
生まれるものは死んだものと少々違うんです
これが 10年ぐらい経ってから気づくんだからね
子供の場合は結構早く成長は気づきますけどね
ですからまあ 私は言うのは
例えばこの音を耳に入るでしょ
音を耳に入るたびに体全体に変化するんです
空気触れるたびに体全体に変化するんです
目に光が当たるたびに体変化するんです
映画を見ていると テレビでもいいんですけど
ずっと自分の体変化しているんです
だから映画に乗っちゃうでしょ
映画が始めた時の気持ちと
どんどん見ていると 途中で気持ちが変わっちゃうでしょ
そういうふうに体が変化するんです
今日はタイムという映画のトレーラーの古い映画ですけどね
テレビで見て そのポイントは面白いポイントがありまして
向こうは俗世間でだらしない意味で使っていたんだけど
ある何かの科学技術を開発して
みんなの腕に何かつけているんです
それで時間入っているんです
あの時間は自分の寿命なんです
それはずっと秒数で減っていくんです
そこで仕事をして しかし
誰も年を取らない あれをつけてもらったら
20歳でつけてもらったら
40年経っても二十歳なんです
体が しかし 時間は 0 0 0になった途端
そのまま死んじゃう そこで仕事をしたり
いろんなことをしたり
みんな時間をもらうんです
それは交換できます 人の手を捕まったら
その人からじゃあ 1時間ちょうだいと言ったら 1
時間その人の命からくれるんです
そういうような感じで
まあ映画自体がすごい面白くないものですが
我々は実際そうなんでしょ
秒単位で減っていくんですよ
年から言えば年は取っていくんですね
だから瞬間瞬間変化しているんです
この変化に生死 生死 生死というんですね
道元禅師もね 生は死である
死は生であるとかね 生死を諦める
諦めないものを諦めるってのであったっけ
はっきりわからないものは仏道はわかりませんよとかね
まあてくてく語ってますけど
そういうわけで 生があったら次に死
物事は瞬間しか成り立たない
すぐ壊れる しかし あったら新たに生まれる
因果法則を発見すればそれはわかります
消える 現れる 消える 現れる
ウッパード バング ウッパード
バングと ヴィパッサナー瞑想上にいったら
これは結構経験しますよ
派手に経験するんです
これバンガニャーというね
そのステージには その時はほとんど自分という気持ちは消えているんです
ただ 何を確認しているかというと
生まれる 消える 生まれる
消える 生まれる 消える
ものすごい忙しい だってもうあらゆるものがあるんだから
そういう時点になったら
まあ大体まあ 1分  2分
3分以内で悟りに達します
集中力壊れなかったならば
はい ですから何言いたいかというと
どこかで生まれて永遠にいるっていうことは馬鹿げた話で
もう小学生ぐらいにも知識のない人間の夢物語であって
絶対ありえないことで
現象の世界では 生まれたやつらはみんな死ななくちゃあかん
神はどうやって作られましたか？神は作る人はいません
神はいないという話になるし
何も創造しなくて何もありえないんだよと平気で言うんですけど
神だけ違いますよと なんでやと聞きたいんだけど
でもこの無常を理解できないんですね
人間に そういうわけで
そういう風な不死ではないんです
不生不死なんです 不生不死は涅槃なんです
はい 次のスライドに行きます
で 生死 生きる命 魂 死後
これ誰でも気になります
生きることは実体として考えるから最善だと考えて
また考える  2つ入りました
執着します 生きるっていうことはすごい何か実体だと
生きてるんだって 何か取られるものやと
取ることはできるものだと思って
それに執着するんです
死は最悪だと思って極端に怯えるんです
だからこちら大事なものがあって
これ壊れる もう大事なものだから
もう執着してるでしょ
これ壊れる ダメダメダメと怯えるんですね
だから生きることがすごい最善であるならば
別にそれでいいでしょう
壊れないでしょ それだったら
仏教は魂 霊魂 アートマンなどの言葉で示す
絶対的 変わらない永遠不滅の実体があると信じることは誤解である錯覚だと言います
で 宗教の場合は霊魂か魂か
ヒンドゥー教出たらアートマンか
なんとか絶対変わらない何かあるんだぞと
絶対変わらない何かあるんだったら見つかるはずなんですね
我々は絶対変わるものでできているんです
考え方も変わるわ 気持ちも変わるわ
健康も変わるわ 年も変わるわ
もうすべて変わるんです
ちょっと音が入っただけでも体全体変わっちゃうんです
だから調べればあるのはすべて変わるもので
何も見つかりません それでお釈迦様は命を全部分解してみたんですね
すべての生命の命はこの 5つに入ります
これ五蘊というんですね
ルーパ ウェーダナ サンニャ
サンカーラ ヴィンニャーナ
色受想行識ですね 日本語で
五蘊で命は成り立っている
ルーパっていうのは物質
物質 はどうしても変化するもので
で 仏教の物質は地水火風だから
もうどうしても変化する
それは素粒子で考えちゃうと
原子だと思っちゃうと変化するんですよ
原子そのものがエネルギーの塊だから
ずっと変化しているんです
エネルギーだから 素粒子だったらもう恐ろしく変化しているんです
だから体構成してる物体がずっと変化する
だからチキン食べたら体の中で鶏の肉が現れないでしょうに
豚肉食べたら まあ 5年間豚肉食べたら自分も豚になるということはありえないでしょう
イスラム教はそう思ってますけど
それはありえないんですね
豚肉食べても魚食べても
人間の体の細胞に変わるんですね
これ変化するからでしょ
我々の細胞壊れると あの細胞のアミノ酸を取って
こちらに必要なアミノ酸を作るんですね
ですから体が変化する
2番目は感覚 感覚が変化しなかったら大変ですよ
サンニャーというのは感覚
感覚なければ生き物じゃないんです
私は命の定義するときは感覚だけにするんです
感じる物体か感じない物体か
例えばマイクロフォンは何も感じない物体ですね
だから物体です この物体は感じるんです
だから生き物です で 感覚というのは
目 耳 鼻 体 どこでも感じるんですよ
私の手はマイクロフォンを触ったら感じるんです
そこをマイクロフォン触ると感じる
手を触ると感じる 同じ感覚だったら
手を触っているとわからなくなっちゃうでしょ
だから感覚変わらなかったら大変なことになるんです
だからこのスクリーン見ると
色を見る 文字見えるでしょ
それなりに感覚が変わるんです
感覚は変わったところ目がチェックするんです
どうやって変わったのかと
そこで脳の中で文字を作るんです
で サンニャーっていうのは概念ですね
で 概念といえばね もうなんでマイクロフォンっていうのは概念で
ペットボトルっていうのは概念で
そういう頭の中でいっぱい概念があるんです
人間だから言葉あるんだけど
言葉は要りません 概念には
猫もこちらを机の上に歩いちゃうと全部区別できます
区別できて ゴートミーの猫だったら
このパソコンがあったらこちらの 위에に寝る
他のところは寝ない だからそれ概念あるんだからなんですね
こちらは寝る場所と まああの
そうやって我々は概念があって
区別判断して生きているんです
サンカーラっていうのは
まあ何かやりたいと ポテンシャル的なエネルギーなんですね
これはずっと生まれるんです
座ったら立ちたくなる
立ったら座りたくなる
ご飯食べたら水を飲みたくなる
そういう風にいつでも何かしたい
何かしたいという衝動があるんです
この衝動はなんで生まれるのかというと
すべて無常だからなんです
無常とは不安定ということなんですよ
アニッチャ 無常 不安定なんです
例えば 食パン 1枚食べちゃっちゃうと
あ 美味しかったじゃなくて
お腹不安定になるんです
喉が不安定になるんです
それで水を飲むんです
それで体不安定になる
それでトイレに行かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
何やっても不安定なんです
で 疲れると体不安定で寝たくなる
寝たら寝たことは不安定で起きたくなる
暑くなったら体を冷やしちゃう
冷えてくると温めるとかね
そういうこと 無常だから
無常とは不安定であって不安定だから
これ変えなくちゃあかん
それは自然に起こるんです
物質法則 物質法則 法則と同じです
精神も不安定で いつでも変化していくんです
この変化したい 変えたいという気持ちがサンカーラというんです
ヴィンヤーナというのは認識すること
これは感覚で認識するんです
例えば 私がこの手に感覚があって
触ると触れたと認識するんです
この五つのスーッと変化する
勢いで変化する 五蘊は因縁によって成り立つんです
で 例えばマイクロフォン
私もこのように触るでしょ
じゃあ触って感じる 今もその感じはありますか？感覚ないんです
じゃあもう一度勝手に作れますか？作れません
マイクロフォンを触った感覚をもう一度感じたいなと感じたい
感じ感じませんよ いくら願ってももう一度感じたければ
あの因縁を合わせなくちゃあかん
もう一度触らなくちゃあかんです
だから変化するんだけど
因縁によって変化する
我々の勝手じゃないんです
で 私がいるところはちょっと
ちょっと冷えているような感じ
皆様のところどうか分かりませんだけどね
で 私にそれ変えられますかね？やっぱり温かく感じよう感じようとできませんね
もし温かさを感じたければ
何か羽織ってもらわないと
これは大事なポイントなんです
五蘊も変化するんだけど
因縁によって変化する
私の勝手ではないんです
だって私も年取りたくないんだけどね
やっぱりダメですよ 私
私の魂 私のアートマン
至福 永遠と言えるべきものは見当たらないんです
それでこの体の中で私
私のアートマン 私の魂
魂は至福であるとヒンドゥー教で言ってるんですね
サッチーアーナンダムと言うんですね
サチダーナンダムと発音するんですね
真理で事実であって それは感じるものであって
アーナンダム至福であると
そんなのないよと この体の中で
見当たらない 調べたら私というのは五蘊に対する誤解です
五蘊で分析しないで 全部まとめて取っちゃうんだから
あ これ私と言うんです
赤ちゃんの写真見て これ私
嘘ばっかり みんな写真撮って私私って言うでしょ
私は私の際に私と言わないんです
まあ言うかもしれませんけど
思わないんです 昔そうでしたの
そうでしたねとかね 私にとっては
自分の写真はいつでも昔の話
姿なんです 今違うと まあ法律的には 3ヶ月間以内で撮った写真出してくれと言うでしょ
それで皆様は 15年前の写真出すでしょ
私はしません この間は何かカードを取らなくちゃあかんだけど
3ヶ月間以内でって言ったら
いっぱいあったんでしょ
その大きさの写真はね
たくさんあった中で すぐその場で撮って
はい どうぞと やっぱり法律的に 3ヶ月間なんですけど
仏教的にはいつでも我々は変化して変化していく
朝 私の顔と今の私の顔は違います
こちらで来た瞬間の 6時半の私の顔と今の顔が違います
まあきれいな顔にはなりませんね
どんどんひどい顔になるだけ
そういうことで 我々はこの概念上
概念使って言葉使って私と言うんですよ
それはただ言語で主語がなければ喋れませんだから構わないんだけど
言語を作ったのはもちろん人間でしょ
だから魂があるんだという意味で作られているんですよ
どうしても主語なく主語を使わないで語れないんですね
愛着と怒り 常に変化する五蘊の一部の変化に愛着する
一部の変化に怯える 嫌がる
恐怖を感じる これどういうことかというと
で 子供が成長するとすごい楽しいでしょ
同じ速度で今も成長していますけど
今嫌ですね 成長するのは
なんだこれと 子供体重に乗せてもらって
どれぐらい体重増えたかと喜んで
ああ よかったよかったとかね
私たちはどうですかね
体重増えてるとすごい
あー嫌だこれはと ある時期体重増えることは喜んじゃって
それに愛着があって ある時期から体重が増えることはものすごく嫌がっちゃうという
いっそだって我々はそういうものなんですね
我々の体の一部を愛着
一部に怖がる 一部を嫌がる
で ご飯食べることで楽しいと美味しいとか
そこを喜ぶ 愛着する 満足になって
お腹がちょっと重くなってくると
あれは気持ちは嫌なんですね
まあ人によりけりますけど
で 私に個人的にも満足ってものすごい気持ち悪いんですよね
だいぶ嫌がるんですね
一部は欲しい 一部は嫌と
でもこんなのはありえない話ですよ
受想行儀式の場合も同じく愛着と怯えを感じるんですね
例えば体で時々何か感じて
ああ 気持ちいい 気持ちいい
ああ 気持ち悪い また同じ感覚なんですけど
暖かくなったら気分がいい
気持ち冷えてくると ああ
気持ち悪い 冷まった 冷まったと
だから感覚の場合も一部欲しい
一部嫌 で 次 概念の場合もね
楽しい妄想 概念回転するとそれはいいんですけど
皆様の頭の中で全然楽しい妄想概念回転しないね
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみの落ち込みの概念ばっかしで
これ嫌ですね 嫌ですけど
やっちゃいますけどね
そこでやりたいという行の場合も同じなんですね
時々ある時やりたいがやりたくないというね
掃除 部屋を掃除したいんだけど
まあしち面倒くさい やめちゃえと
やっぱりやりたいんだけど
やっぱり後にしますとかね
あれってすごい気分が悪いでしょ
その場合は互い違いの業が生じているんですね
掃除するべきと言ったっても
エネルギーはあまり生まれてこない
怠けの方のエネルギー
怠けたいという業が強いんですね
それで頭の中で喧嘩するんですね
私も時々冷蔵庫の品物がなくなったら
じゃあ買い物したい しなくてはと
で 外を見たらペラペラと雨が降っていて
ちょこちょこ まあ嫌ですねとかね
もうちょっとしたから行きますと
もうちょっと他のことをやってから行きますと
言って見せしまいで ということになるんですね
そこで頭の中でこのやらなくてはという気持ちと
怠けたいという気持ちがぶつかってぶつかって
あまり面白くないんで
その状況は 色の場合も一部の色が欲しくて
一部の色が嫌がるんです
自分が愛着する五蘊の一部だけが永遠に続いてほしいと期待する
これってあり得ないこと
この体の一部だけ永遠にしてほしいと
どんな部分部品ですかね
日本でもいたんですね
人間が天国に生まれましょうとか言ってる人がね
天国に行ったら みんなおじいちゃん
ひいおじいちゃん ひいひいひいひいおじいちゃん
みんな一緒になるんだよと
みんな二十歳の体でいるんだよと
気持ち悪いんですけどね
で だからいかにアホかっていうことはわかるでしょ
本人もすごい年取ってじじいになって死んじゃったんだけど
やっぱり二十歳の肉体が欲しがっていたんですね
よくもこんなバカなことを期待して
節と期待するんだからね
これは決して叶えられる期待ではないのです
あ 最後の行が それで期待する
若くて若くなりたい 若くなりたい
期待するでしょ 結果は年取るでしょ
そうするともっと若くなりたい
若くなりたがってに もうあれが強くなっちゃうんです
これ悪循環になるんです
いわゆる叶え 叶わ 叶うことをできない希望がどんどん強烈に上がるんです
とんでもないアホになってしまうんです
はい それはカスアイというんですね
常に変化する五蘊は希望通りに変化しない
体は変化する 心は変化する
気持ちは変化する 感覚は変化する
現に接近で物事を見るたびに
聞くたびに 味わうたびに変化する
しかし 自分好きなようじゃない
です 焼き魚おいしいな
食べたいなと ある味を期待しているんですね
食べてみたら塩が足らない
やっぱりこれ塩が足らない
塩が足らないなんて魚食べたかったです
だから喜べばいいでしょうにと
これ不可能でしょう だから何かおいしいものを食べて
おいしい感覚を味わいたい
味わいたいなと思っても
その品物によって味が生まれるんだから
自分勝手ではできません
因縁によって起こるんです
この動き 働きは経験しているんです
我々は 皆さんも知ってますよ
自分の希望通りにいかないんだと
すごく暖かくいたいんだけど
外に出たら寒いんですよ
希望通りにいかないんです
雨に濡れたくないんだけど
傘を差さないで雨の中に入っちゃうと濡れちゃいます
希望通りにいかないんです
徹夜して頑張るぞと思ったっても眠くなります
しかし ありのままの事実を認めたくないんですね
しかし 認めたくないんです
だから腹が立ったり 例えば
受験生たちがもうずっと徹夜して勉強すればいいでしょ
1週間ぶっ続けとかね
でも無理です すぐ寝ちゃうんです
自分の希望通りにいかない
それで目が覚めたら あー嫌だ
もう寝てしまっちゃった
勉強できなかったとか
また悩むんです 例えばお釈迦様が言うのは
年取りたくないという希望がある
絶対叶わない それで激しく悩むそうと
病気になりたくないという希望があるでしょ
しかし かかります それでひどく悩みますよと
死にたくはないと希望があるでしょうにと
絶対叶わないんだ だから死が近寄ってくると
この場合はこの体の死ですね
すごく怯えるんだよと
それで 愛着から叶わない希望が生じる
叶わない希望からさらに愛着が生じるという流れで
どんどん悪循環になるんです
どんどん渇愛が強くなるんです
生きていきたい 死にたくないという気持ちがどんどん強くなるんです
例えば 生きていきたいという気持ちが
15歳の子供よりは 80歳の人には強いんです
これ 渇愛ですね 生死のあれやりました
生死は一つの現象の表と裏です
これを説明しました 死があって
生があって 死が成り立つ
死によって生が成り立つ
生きるとは生死の流れです
誕生した人が死ぬわけではありません
一つの流れが壊れる 現象的な死ことだけ気にするのは
無明と渇愛のせいです
我々は今何々さんで 私はスマナサーラで死んじゃうことだけ気になっちゃうんです
あ これは嫌ですよとかね
これってもう渇愛なんです
今も死んでいるんだからね
そんなに気にしなくても
死のおかげで生きているんです
だから仏道を知っている人は死は気にしない
だって毎日のこと 毎瞬のことだから
私たちはそれを無視して
業無視して 今ここにいる私が死にたくないと思っちゃうんです
生として業が現れたら
現象的な死を迎える前に老いること
病 悩み 憂い 悲しみ 何でしたっけ
悲しみ 苦しみ 希望が叶わない
嫌なことと遭遇するなどの苦しみから逃げられない
まずこの世で業が現れますね
それで業が変化しながらずっと流れるでしょ
その間であらゆる苦しみがあるんです
要するに 生苦であり 苦の始まりでもあります
ですから もし永遠に生まれる場所があったならば
そちらで生まれた途端
永遠の生でしょ ですから
永遠の苦です 業因に対する渇愛
業因の流れを司る様々な原因の中で大きな原因です
それで理解しておきましょう
私たちの体が勝手に変化しないと言ったでしょ
因果法則なんですね その中で渇愛も一つの原因なんです
渇愛によって変化するんです
この渇愛の変化がすごく怖いんです
年取りたくないと思うのは渇愛でしょ
思えば思うほど年取ることが早くなっちゃうんです
早く細胞は老けるんです
それが因果法則です 金が欲しい欲しい欲しいと思うとなくなるんです
心の法則をわかってないんだからそう思うんであって
で それで渇愛と無明がありまして
これを 2つの巨大な原因なんですね
気にするべき輪廻の原因は 1無明に渇愛です
だから人が死ぬ時が無明がすごく巨大になる
渇愛も巨大になる この二人がまた業を作るんです
だから無明って悪いものでしょ
渇愛 悪いものでしょ 変でしょ
だからあんまりいいところに生まれませんね
今も業は絶えず変化し続けるので
輪廻なのです 今も私たちは輪廻しています
しかし 業は因縁により生じて滅するのであって
自分の希望通りになりません
今も輪廻していますけど
自分の希望通りには輪廻しないんです
因縁によって しかし 個人が渇愛は重大な原因の個人の渇愛は重大な原因の原因
2つの一つです したがって
体が壊れても 渇愛によって新たな命が現れます
渇愛によって新たな命が現れます
それから新たな死を迎えなくちゃいけない
新たな苦しみ 悩みに遭遇しなくちゃいけない
これは輪廻転生 それから生老病死の循環ですね
はい 節に入ります もうそろそろ終わります
死のない生はありえない
これも説明しました 節が欲しければ不祥も期待しなくちゃあかんです
しかし 生まれてから決して死なないことを期待します
しかし 我々は生まれたらあ
死にたくない 死にたくない
死にたい こればっかり期待するんです
極端な妄想 これ誤解です
釈尊は五蘊に対する愛着を完全に捨てることで
生も死も成り立たない環境を境地を経験できると説かれます
これ言葉にならない 概念にならない経験なんですね
例えばこの体物体がね
ずっと変化していることを見えたら
感覚 認識 概念ずっと変化していることを見えたら
私って何ですかと これはありえないんだと
何に執着していたんですかと
何に怒っていたんですかと
あらっと 幻覚に蜃気楼に夢に
夢で 1 000万円をもらったことがあって
私は 1 000万持ってる持ってると思ってるようなことなんです
いつも だって夢でもらいましたよと
夢 1 000万のところか 1億をもらってもね
それに愛着したっても意味がないでしょ
だから私に対する愛着
渇愛は夢に対する愛着
渇愛であったと発見するんです
それで渇愛は消える それでも言葉に絶対ならない
一般人には絶対理解できない自由
解放感が味わうんです
それが不死の境地なんです
そちら生もなし 死もなし
その人は死んじゃったら涅槃です
それによ それには現象をありのままに見ることで起こる智慧が必要です
現象をありのままに見ると智慧が現れます
それそんな難しいことでもないんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想は難しくないんだからね
無常なのに無常ではないと思うこと
自我がないのにあると思うこと
死ぬのに老いるのに 病にかかるのに
不死 無老 無病を期待することで
人は苦難に陥って苦を続けるんです
なんで我々は苦ばかり続けるかというと
無常なのに無常ではないと思う
自我がないのに自我があると思う
死ぬのに死なないと思う
老いるのに老いない その代わりに不死
無老 無病を期待する だから苦難に陥る
この苦の循環から脱出することが解脱
涅槃 不死なんです この循環から脱出するんです
どこかに生まれるわけじゃないんです
不生不死なんです 理解できる言葉は苦を乗り越えるです
だから仏道で皆様に理解できる単語を使えば
苦を乗り越えるということで修行してほしい
涅槃に達したい 不死になりたいと思わないでください
それは理解できないんです
不死とは悟った方しか知らないんです
ですから 我々一般人に理解できるのは
この苦しみはなんとかしたい
この怒り 嫉妬 憎しみはなんとかしたい
そういうふうに苦を乗り越えるという言葉で
仏教は大体語ら語るんです
ドゥッカッサンタンカリシェティということで
不死とは 宗教家が語っ誤って使っていた単語を正しく使うことです
お釈迦様が使っている不死あまたとは
宗教家が間違って使った単語を直しただけです
達するべき境地であると感覚的に感じるだけで
具体的に理解できる言葉ではありません
だから今日 不死に対して講演しましたけど
不死ということは具体的に理解することはちょっとできません
感覚的になんとか理解できればよろしいんです
それは今から頑張って達するべきものです
阿羅漢に達したい人 あるいは預流果にでも達したい人は
あ こういう自由な境地あるんだとわかるんです
はい これで今日のお話は終了します
で わかりやすく例えで言えばね
この夢でたくさん金もらって
その夢でもらった金に執着している
それは永遠にあってほしいと思う
で 目が目が覚めたら 1円もないんです
だから この世間が語っている不死っていうのは
この夢でもらった宝物なんです
仏教が語る それで足が引っ張られますよ
何するか分からないんだから
こいつは金持ちの気分だからね
やること全部ダメなんです
それで仏教が語る不死は夢から目を覚ます
覚まったら何もないやと
別に普通にいるんです
それは自由なんです はい
以上です  はい それでは少し時間がございますので
マイクを回したいと思います
もし質問ある方いらっしゃいましたら挙手していただければマイク回しますので
はい では 一番前の  お話ありがとうございました
2つ質問してもよろしいでしょうか
1つ目が 今まさに自殺をしようとしている人がいたら
なんと声をかけるかというもの
もう一つが あの許せないって思うことが生きていると多々あると思うんですけど
悪を懲らしめるという発想についてどう思われるか
あと  えーと 悪を懲らしめるという考えとか行動についてどう思われるか
お聞かせいただけますでしょうか
あの自殺しようとしている人々にはね
うーん まああんまり別にあの
その人にいろいろ質問した方がいいんですね
なんで自殺を考えているのかと
何が嫌なのかと よく喋らせてほしい
喋ると喋ると この心の中で溜まってる感情がまあどんどん運んだからね
人に言うと結構柔らかくなりますね
それから死んでからあんたはどうなりたいんですかと
どう思いますかと あれは決して死ぬなよ
自殺するなよだけは言わないでください
あんただってすごいこと考えてるんだよと
私にはそんなこと想像もできないんだと
ということで ちょっとおだててあげて
ずっとこの質問して その人の世界を解明してもらうんです
そうすると どんどんあの
できればね まあなんか臭いなって方向へ持っていった方が
すごいことだと思ったんだけど
なんか薄くて 私はそういうことを考えませんとかね
そういう風に言っちゃうと
もしかすると治るかも
その一応自殺したがるのは
この喝采がありすぎちゃってね
自我がありすぎちゃってね
世の中うまくいかないんですね
その人にとって 我々にとってももういかないでしょ
でも我々にはそんなに自我がないんですね
人に怒鳴られたらまあしょうがないということで落ち着くでしょ
で その時自我がありすぎちゃうと
怒鳴られた それ認めたくないんですね
なんで怒鳴られたのかと
いじめられたらなんでやと
でも普通の人々は世の中って甘くないやと
優しくないんだと いじめるやつらもいるんだと知ってるんだから
自我の程度がいくらか弱いんですね
あれで自我のあれ程度がちょっと
リミット超えてますね
それで強烈な怒りが出てくるんです
生命には存在欲は強烈にあるんです
生きていきたいという同時に怯えもあるんです
で それで我々の場合は存在欲がちょっと強くて
怯えがちょっと低いんです
恐怖感は低いんです これであまりにも自我がありすぎちゃうと
存在欲が減って恐怖感が上がっちゃうんですね
そこで自殺っていう気持ちになっちゃうんです
ですから この自我がありすぎるところね
世の中はそんなもんですけどね
かえってね あなたより私の状況はもっとひどいやと思いますけど
私はあんまり気にしませんよとかね
だからこの人言うでしょ
あれが悪い これが悪い
これうまくいかなかった
これはあの人一つうまくいかなかったことをぼさっと言っちゃうと
あんた 10個ぐらい言ってあげてください
私の場合は これもこれもこれもこれもうまくいかなかったと
それもしかしくない 考えてみれば
もうほとんどうまくいってないんだからね
人生は そういうふうに話すしかないんですよ
まあ自殺するなよという一言葉だけは意味がないんです
これは人に命令することだからね
人は人の命令聞かないんです
なんか我々 人の話を聞いてるような気がするでしょ
聞いてないんです 本当は
人は言ったことをやる場合でも
自分がやりたいんだからやったんです
だから何か行動が自発的に自分で生まれなくちゃいけない
サンカールと書いた衝動なんですね
ですから 本人にそのサンカーラが生まれるところまで話を話してあげなくちゃいけないんですね
ちょっと難しいんですけどね
でも本人のことを本当に心配するならば
言葉は自動的に出てきます
ただ言って意味がないのは
自殺したら地獄に落ちるぞとかね
あれやこれやとかね 尊い命だから大事にしなさいよとかね
あんなのはくだらん言葉で何の意味もないんです
だから本人に聞く あんた死んでからどうするつもり？とかね
普通日常生活は苦しいですけど
あんた知ってますかね？自殺
死ぬっていうことは極端に苦しい
それぐらい自信があったら
だってものすごい苦しいんだよ
毒飲んでも首吊ってもね
その瞬間っていうのはもう耐え難い苦しみですよ
自然に死ぬ場合はね お医者さんでも薬でもくれますから
楽ですよ そんなに勇気あったらね
生きてみれば死ぬほど苦しくないでしょ
はい そういうふうに何とか話してみてください
2番目はちょっと理解できなかった
ちょっとはっきりと 佐藤さん
何でしたっけ？えーと
例えばこの人許せないなとか
社会的倫理的に反しているようなことを平然とやっているような人たちを懲らしめたいという感情だったり
考えだったり 思いというのが湧くと
湧く人もまあ僕湧いたりするんですけど
いると思うんですが そういうあの悪っていうものを懲らしめるっていうような発想
罰 罰 こちらが罰する側に回る
そういった仕返しをするとかですね
そういった全体に悪いことをしたんじゃないか
この人がっていう人に対する
その懲らしめるという発想は
あのどう  はいはい わかりました
これはあの ものすごく怒りなんですね
やはり自分が悪いことは許せないと思った瞬間
なんか自分がいい人間のつもりですが
自分がすごく怒っているんですね
それも関係ない人に怒っているんですよ
あなたの友達 あなたを蹴ったら
その人に怒ってぶん殴るのは構わない
それどうったことない
友達同士ですからね でも
お母さんに何か頼んでも頼んでやってくれないんだったら
お母さん見てこれ全然やってくれないんだという
お母さんと怒ったってもね
そんな小さなことでね
大したことないんですよ
しかし その怒りがすごい立ち位置が悪いんです
また危険です なぜならば
世の中で理不尽なこと
不幸なこと いけないことっていうのはありすぎ
あまりにも それによって自分が怒ってしまっちゃうと
極端な犯罪者になってまっちゃう可能性もありますね
行動的な人間だったら犯罪者になっちゃうんですね
行動力なかったら自分だけ燃えて自己破壊で終わっちゃいますけどね
だからもう確かにやってはいけないことを人間がやっている
悪いことをいっぱいやっている
それに怒ると 自分自身も悪いことをしているんですよ
結局は  怒るということ自体が悪い
うん で どうせ世の中の不幸
不平不満 理不尽なことを放っておくのかと
それはもうちょっとまずいんですね
その場合は怒るんじゃなくて
みんなで話し合って できるだけのグループを作って話し合って
できるだけこういうことのないように
我々は仲良くするようにしましょうよとかね
で あるいは悪いことする人々は
まあそれなりの警察やら法律とかね
そういうところでまあちゃんと罰を受けるようにしてあげましょうと
その人々もやっぱりそれを理解してほしいと
例えば金を横領したというならば
その悪いことの苦しみはその人を味わった方がよろしいんですよ
そうすると ああ 私が悪いことをしたって反省は感じるでしょ
それは自分がやるんじゃないんですね
個人でやるものじゃない
それは社会で組織でやるんです
組織に罪はないんだからね
で だいたい私たちは仏教の世界だから
我々に教えられるのは
世の中の悪いことを見ると
自分が決してそういう生き方はしませんと自分を戒めるんです
私も小さい時からもう私の周りに出ると
そんないい人間ではなかったんです
ずっと私に対してものすごく理不尽なことや
とんでもないことをものすごいやったんですね
やられるたびに私は 私はそういうことは誰にもやりませんと
って決めて決めて 自分を磨いて磨いて磨いてきたんですね
今もいるんですけど とんでもないことをやろうと企んでる連中がね
私はかえってまあどうそうと
私はやりませんと 司会はしませんと
いうふうなことで 自分を育てるためのチャンスにするんです
人間というのはみんなまあ不完全だから
これは期待できないんですね
人は嘘言ってはいけないでしょ
しかし 真理を語る社会は期待できません
せいぜいできるのは 私は嘘つきませんよ
それだけですね そういうことで
自分の心の中にこみ上げてくる怒りを制御した方がいいんじゃないかなと
で 慈しみさえあれば みんなでできるはず
何かそういう悪いことを減らす方法ないのかと行動的に考えても構わない
それは社会に対する貢献であって
慈しみの行動であってほしい
はい 以上です  ありがとうございます
他にご質問ある方いらっしゃいますか？はい
えーと 後ろの方の女性の方がどうしたらいいですか？はい
はい こちらこちら右側
よろしくお願いします
役に立とうとすると欲が出てくるんですが
役に立ちながら無執着を目指していくにはどのようにしたらよろしいでしょうか
役に立とうとすると  欲が出てくるんですが
無執着を目指しながら役に立とうとしていくにはどうしたらよろしい
ですか それは役に立とうと思うんじゃなくて
なんか自分が見返りを期待してるんですね
それがダメなんですね
役に立つことで自分が人格的に成長するんだと
それは自然に起こるんだから
人に何かしてあげて その人にありがとうございますって言われてほしいとかね
ありがとうぐらい言いなさいと
そこはダメなんですよ
そういうこの役に立って
それに対する見返りを期待する場合は欲になっちゃうの
自我になるんですね しかし
役に立つ生き方こそが素晴らしい生き方なんですね
だから 自分自身が素晴らしい生き方をしなくてはいけないと決めるんです
私は 私の良心が私に批判しない
非難しない生き方をしますと
自分を自己観察すると
まあそれなりに街で生きているんだと
思ってほしい 自分で自分の人生を見る
私の生き方ってどういうことかと
それなりに街じゃないな
ないんですかね とかね
真っ直ぐにということはできませんだからね
私は最高にいい人生だっていう風なことはあり得ませんだから
まあそれなりにぼちぼち
生きているんだというふうに
自分の良心が自分を非難しない生き方をする
そうすると欲が出てこないんですね
どうして他人の役に立つことで
自分が有意義な生き方をしていることになるんです
例えば 私が料理を作って自分一人で食べても
あまり面白くないんですね
しかし 人に料理作ってあげる
あげて その人が本当にそれを食べて幸せになったら
自分が役に立ったと それで自分が自分を評価すればいいんです
で 子供なんかね ご飯あげてもパクパク食べちゃって
そのまま出て行っちゃうんですね
ごちそうさんという一言葉さえも忘れちゃうんですね
でも 食べてそのまま皿の辺りあちらこちら放り投げちゃって
元気で走り回っちゃうと
あーよかったなとか思えばいいんじゃないんですかね
そういうことで 世間から見返りを期待しない
私は有意義に生きるということは
私の人格の生き方の問題であるということで
自分が有意義な生き方をするということに決めちゃえば
欲が出てこないと思います
はい 頑張ってください
ありがとうございます
あと一人ぐらい時間ありますけど
どうでしょう では いや
そちらの奥にの女性の方
先に  お願いします この 2年ぐらいの悩みなんですけども
ずっと本当にくだらないと思うんですけど
なんかお金持ちでかっこいい男の人と結婚したいなっていう妄想が止まらなくて
その欲を消したくて 妄想が出てきたらそう思っていると
サティはしているんですけど
もうずっと昼も夜も本当に
ちょっと笑わないでください
質問結構なくなります
この渇愛をなくして楽にする方法は
妄想が出てきた時にサティをする以外ないのでしょうか？
そんな気にしなくていいんじゃないですかね
本当に 本当にいつも考えてしまうんです
で 夜寝る前 サティをしても気づいたら寝てしまって
朝起きた時にはもうお金持ちの男の人と結婚して
もう出産 妊娠もう全部終わって目が覚めるっていう
本当に毎日その繰り返し
うん  本当に消えない  なるほど
まああの まあそれまあ大体ね
女の子たちでね まあよくある話ですから
あの このジェーン・オースティンとかね
昔のイギリスのね あの女性の作家たち
有名人書いてる小説をね
その話ばっかしでね で
私は学生時代は英語の勉強のために読みましたけど
もう最近も本いくつか読んでみたんですね
気持ち悪いね あの話はね
で 何でも完璧な男でお金むちゃくちゃあって
もう俺と結婚して まあ自分をお姫様として全部面倒見てくれるっていうね
まあだからまあこれ妄想しすぎですからね
現実はまた違うしね はい
現実的に考えると この金持ちっていうのはそれほど性格が良くないんですよ
あの普通 あの自分の楽しみで思うのは構わないんですよ
まあそういうね いろんな妄想遊び
人間やってますから あの妄想遊びやどという感じにするのは構わないんだけど
この現実的に金持ちっていうのは
まあ性格的にはすごく悪いんですよ
ほとんどの場合はね ありえないんですね
性格も良くて金もいっぱいあるっていうことは成り立たないんです
あの 今日私は国のテレビ局でね
まあいろいろ漫才みたいなものを聞いていて
で 王様のキャラがあって
王様の妃たちがね まあとんでもないことを言って
王様が反対するんです
そしたらお前もうぶん殴ってやるぞと王さんに怒るんですね
そしたら王様がほら見て
こいつら私も殴ろうとしてるんだからと
ですから 大臣に外出禁止令出しなさい
こいつらにと で あの大臣がね
まあなんか犬猫の感じでお妃たちのことを言うんですね
そしたら王様怒って 何を私の妃たちにと言ったら
あの王様ね あの王様が何でもあの連中にあげて
あいつら犬よりも下やと
もう 1 日 10回ぐらい食べて
もうお化粧消したい放題して
何やこれやと 人間じゃありませんと
人間っていうのは特に食べるものもなくて
やっとなんか仕事をして
なんか 1 日頑張って生きてる人々のところに
優しさも思いやりも何でもありますよという冗談でしたけど
全然冗談にならないね
私は言ったら で で そういうことだから
なかなかね あの金も金と一緒に付いてくるのは悪いことばっかりなんですよ
実はお互い友達でね お互いいろんなことを話し合って
もうお互いの弱みを打ち明けて
それぞれお互い補ってあげて
まあ楽しみも苦しみも一緒に分かち合って生きることが究極の幸せなんです
究極かどうかはわかりませんだけど
結婚の幸せはそういうことなんですね
夢見るのはもう別に まあそれはもう適当で夢見てください
で はいはい 私は謎はありますよ
いろいろこの金持ちと結婚したケースいっぱいあるでしょ
日本では 日本でもね このタレントさんやらね
あの人々はどうなっているのかとちょっと調べてみたら
結婚式にも億単位で使っちゃうでしょ
しかし 二 三年で終わりですね
だからそういうふうに具体的なデータをちょっと取ってみたら
あ これは物語だけで十分やってるになるかもしれません
で わからないんで 人の運命っていうのはね
あなたに もしかすると金持ちの人
まあかわいそうに見つかるかもしれませんだけど
で それはわからないんだけど
これだけ言いたいんですね
この渇愛で 例えば金持ちと必ず結婚しようと思っちゃうと
逆になっちゃうんですね
自分が養ってあげなくちゃいけない羽目になる可能性もあります
ですから そこはちょっと危険なんですね
ではなくて どうか私の性格に合うやつが見つけたら結婚しますよと
何よりも先に性格が合いますかということは大事ですよということにしてください
で 大事なのは性格 金ではないんです
で そういうことで 特に日本でね
それなりの生活できるぐらい収入はあるんだからね
みんなに そこはあまり考えるポイントではありません
だって あなたにとっても
むちゃくちゃ金入っちゃうとね
超つまらないと思いますよ
このブランドのカバンやらアクセサリーやら身についちゃってね
行くところもなくて 毎日同じ人の顔ばっかり見ているね
あれってすごい気持ち悪いんですよ
本当は ですから この とにかくよく調べてください
このごっつい金持ちはどうなっているのかとかね
昔の話ですけど ジョン・Ｆ・ケネディの奥さんがね
ジャクリーンさんがね
で いい加減な女で ケネディさんが死んじゃったら
このオナシス アルフレッドオナシスという世界一金持ちと結婚したでしょ
で 結婚したんだけど 結婚契約にサインして同じどこかに行っちゃうんですね
忙しくて すごい忙しい人で
だから何の結婚かと ただ
ただケネディの奥さんと結婚したんだというだけの話なんですね
あの人から見れば この女もケネディ家よりもすごい金がある家に入ったということで
金の無駄遣いで 例えば店に行ったら自分気に入ってるブランドの服があったら
これ全て買うみたいですね
あの このデザイナーが作るでしょ
そちらに連絡して作ったものを全部まとめて買う
例えばもしかすると先着かもしれませんよ
でも着ないでしょ 本人が
なんで買うのかというと
同じ服は他の人を着るのは嫌なんです
だからお金でいい加減なお金で言えば
例えば 10万円で 1着買えますけど
この人はそれにはまあまあ 1億円使うんですね
だってこの このデザインを提出しなくちゃあかんだからね
それでオナシスどうしたかというと
オナシスさんにもこのお金ではかなり大変な問題になっちゃって
禁止しちゃったんです
金使うの 月々これぐらい以上使えないということに制限されて
カードをあげたんですね
だからそれって生きてるんですかね
あれって幸せですかね
あんな嫉妬で あんな恨みで
それより皆様方はものすごい幸せですよ
そういうことだから 具体的なデータを調べた方がよろしいんですよ
ちょっとした楽しみのために
まあ悪くないんだけど
だいたい女性の方々はだいたいそういう楽しみがあるみたいですからね
白馬に乗った王子様と結婚したいっていうのはね
まあまあ それはそれ 私は何とも言いません
しかし もう大人ですから
ちゃんとデータを見てください
結婚するといえば 生の人間と結婚するんだからね
はい 以上です  はい あの後ろの方にもう一人手を挙げている方いらっしゃったと思うんですけど
その方に回していただけますか？中段の向かって左側の
その方で最後でお願いします
よろしくお願いします
あのサンガジャパンの最新号で戒律の特集でしたけれども
その中でちょうどカーメジニッチャターラのところで
今までの不倫という意味の他に
諸々の欲に対して不適切な行為という広い意味があるということをおっしゃってましたけども
その部分を前後何回か読み返したんですが
それでは従来通りの不倫をしないという解釈でいいのか
それとももっと幅を広げて取りなさいというのか
はっきりおっしゃっていないように思われるんですけども
そこら辺がもう少し説明していただきたいのと
あと五戒の前に八戒がありますけど
そのところでブラフマチャリアという風に書かれますが
従来から性行為という風に言われてますけども
もう一回辞書を引きながら見ると
梵天として不適切な性行為という風にも解釈できるように思うんですけど
そこら辺も含めてお願いしたいと思います
あの この項目を唱えて戒律を守るということは
この宗教世界から現れたもので
仏教の道徳っていうのは常識的に道徳を守ることなんですけどね
でも人間がそれわからないんだから
まあ項目を作るのこといけなくなったんですね
で 五戒もお釈迦様が別に開発したものではなくて
世間でだいたい誰でも正しいと認めることにしましたし
それでこのインドでね
あの宗教家たちがね 家を出ている宗教家たちの大半はアッダマチャリアというね
まあ戒律を守っていたんですね
で 出家っていうのは あの家族を離れて外に出ることだから
あの結婚しないとかね
異性と関係を持たないっていう
性行為全くしないっていうことが
あのすごく派手に見えてきたんですね
で ですから この出家イコールブラフマチャリー
ブラフマチャリーという風になっちゃうんですね
そういうことで しかし
在家の方々にとってはそれが無理な話
で で そこを変えてカーメスミチャーチャーラって欲質な行為しないっていうことに変えるんですね
いわゆる性行為しないではなくて
欲質な行為をしないということでね
で あのブラフマチャリアを在家のバージョンとして柔らかくしたんですね
それで仏教は定義は好きだから
注釈書などなどで定義するんですね
欲質な行為っていうのは
この  異性との関係で この他人に守られている人と性行為してはいけないんだと
そうすると 特に女性っていうのは死ぬまで守られているんだと
小さい時は親を守っていて
親が守る 結婚したら夫が奥さんを守る
年取ったら子供たちがお母さんを守ると
まあ体は弱いんですですから
やっぱり守る守る守ってあげなくちゃいけないという考えがありまして
で そういうことで 他人が他人が守っている女性なんですね
みんな そうすると 自分が守る女性っていうのは自分の奥さんですから
奥さんとの行為は OK です
それ以外はやるなよということで定義して定着しているんです
それはブラフマチャリアの
在家バージョンですね
それで私はカーメスと
なんで複数の単語を使っているのかと
カーミーミッチャーチャーラといえば性行為だけにできますけど
カーメスなんですね 諸々の欲において悪いことをしないという直訳になるんですね
そこでカーマっていうのは五欲ですね
現に身心の女性との性行為は五欲も入ってますよ
女性も説かれていますけどね
だって男性の立場から見れば
女性を見て楽しむ 匂いを楽しむ
観測を楽しむ 女性の声を楽しむ
もう全部五欲も感じるんですね
で 女性もその通りに男性から五欲を感じるということになるんですね
だからカーメスミチャーチャーラではないかという定義もあります
しかし 私はもっと仏教というのはすごい品格のある宗教だから
宗教といえばね 品格のある教えですから
もうもっと違う ちゃんとカーメス複数形で取った方がいいんじゃないかなと
そうなってくると 我々俗世間でいろんなものを見て楽しむんですね
しかし やりすぎは良くないでしょう
いくらなんでも音を楽しむでしょ
でも聞きすぎは良くないでしょ
味を楽しむでしょ でも食べる
食べ過ぎはだらしないんでしょう
そこで節度をとって五欲を味わう
適当に見るものを見て
聞くものを聞いて 味わうものを味わって
例えば車があったら体の楽しみでしょ
だから言って５台６台買う必要ないでしょ
これはやりすぎですね
映画見るのは構わないんだけど
朝から晩まで見ちゃうと
あれ毎日決まった映画館に行っちゃうとやりすぎですね
美味しいものを食べるのは構わないんだけど
朝も昼も夜もいつでも極度に美味しいものばっかり探して食っちゃうと
これはあの自分を自制する
コントロールするということが消えちゃうんですね
自己管理ないってことなんですね
そういうことだから まあ他のものにもちょっと気をつけた方がいいんじゃないかなと
いわゆる節度を知るというね
節度する 欲質な行為の場合はね
自分の奥さんとい以外はダメという意味なんですけど
ブッダの時代では一人が奥さん一人もらうという習慣決まってなかったんですね
男性に養うことできれば
二人もらうことも三人もらうこともできたし
王様は何人もおしゃれで見栄張ってたくさんもらっちゃうしね
それでも自分の奥さんなんですね
だから だからそれを関係ない
もし社会でね 女性が夫男二人と結婚するのは合法的やと言ったら
それも構わないんですね
法律的に決めているんだからね
まあ自然法則で見れば一人でもまあものすごい大変だから
まあもう一人になったんですけどね
その何人ということ仏教は決まってないんです
そこであの売春制度 インドでありましたからね
で 若い人は売春のところに行くのはあれに入らないんです
カーメスのチャージャーに
なぜかというと その時間お金払ってるんだからね
払って一時的に自分の奥さんにしているんですね
それはやってくださいと言ってるわけじゃなくて
この仏教戒律 法律的に解説するとそうなるんです
で だって有名なそういう芸者さんみたいにね
何人かいて で この一日線量を取るんです
一日 だからそれはすごい品格のある仕事で
絶世の美人が決めるんですね
彼女が線量もらって 一日二十四時間
その人の奥さんとして仕事をする
だから料理は上手で 歌は上手で
踊りは上手で 言葉遣い何でもかんでも完璧にできて習うんだ
それは だから金持ちの人々はなんとか金を集めて
一日だけでもあの絶世の美人と完璧な奥さんを一日味わいたいというようなこともあって
それはあまり仏教は批判してないんですね
なぜかというと この二人いたんですよ
インドに このそういう美人が
この二人とも仏教徒になったんです
お釈迦様の信者さんになったんです
一人が悟りに達したんです
ですから まあお釈迦様
あんたら方はこのふしだらな生活をやめなさいと言ったわけじゃないでしょ
ふしだらな性格ではないんですね
そういうことで 性行為に対してはそんな程度なんですね
しかし 我々はね まあ立派な人間として
他の楽しみも節度を知った方がいいんじゃないかなという私の意見なんですね
以上です  よくわかりました
どうもありがとうございます
はい それではこれで終了したいと思います
最後に回向の文を皆さんでお唱えしたいと思いますので
合掌してください  回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に来拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨ エワンジャントゥ サッブローゴー ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワントアンテラヨー スッキーリ
ー ガイコー バワ バワトゥ サッブマンガラング ラッカント サッブデーヴァタ サッブゴンドゥ
anu bhaven sabba dhamma nu bhaven sabba sangha nu bhave
n sada sutti bhavantu
te abhivadana sii lisso niccaang vadda pacayino cattaro dhamma vadantti ayu
vannu sukham balam
では 幸福でありますように
どうもありがとうございます